all right thank you both our dr. David
agus joins us now from Los Angeles with
the bigger picture on the race to
develop a vaccine David good morning how
promising is the news we just have from
dr. Hogan moderna it's a small step so
two shots and you can get antibody
levels that we think may be protective
there's also the t-cell part of immunity
that wasn't described so this is a
beginning of the science here it's a
necessary step I'm certainly glad that
it did this but there's a long way to go
in that particular vaccine David we
heard the Health and Human Services
Secretary Alexei czar say that the goal
is to create 300 million doses of a
vaccine and have it available by the end
of the year how likely is that
I don't think it's likely they're gonna
have 300 million doses of a vaccine the
end of the year remember as a country
this took two doses we just heard in the
moderna we're gonna need 600 million
doses as a country I think we'll have
millions of doses by the end of the year
I think we'll be starting to vaccinate
people who are the medical frontline
individuals as well as high-risk
individuals and potentially if their
outbreaks in individual cities we can
start to vaccinate there to stop or to
quell those outbreaks I don't think
we're gonna have enough to start with
the whole country at that time while
that's ongoing more production will
happen and over the next year we'll
start to be vaccinating the rest of the
country right
have we ever manufactured a vaccine in
those quantities and that kind of a
timeline no I mean if you think about it
most vaccines are synchronous you had
the vaccinated childhood h2 h3 h-12 for
HPV 65 for Pneumovax and so we're used
to making a certain amount at a time
this is making obviously enough to do
two shots to the whole country is
something that is heroic and very hard
to organize very hard to put together as
well as the production side so one of
the other things that secretary a czar
said was that may need multiple vaccines
and a booster shot explain that if you
would so in
many vaccines you get an initial shot
and we call a booster which means like
in this vaccine that moderna just talked
about you know several weeks later a
second shot to really boost the immune
system and then coronavirus classically
every year the immune system will go
down to it and so you may need to be
boosted again on a yearly basis so this
may be an ongoing vaccine protocol for
the country and it may be different by
age you know if you're 30 years old you
probably will need one or two vaccines
you may need a lot more if you're
elderly or very young because those
immune systems aren't as mature don't
respond as well to vaccines all right
dr. David agus thank you David